and how to find their way to their old nesting grounds
and feeding grounds.
There were some conservationists,
really famous conservationists like Stanley Temple,
who is one of the founders of conservation biology,
and Kate Jones from the IUCN, which does the Red List.
They're excited about all this,
but they're also concerned that it might be competitive
with the extremely important efforts to protect
endangered species that are still alive,
that haven't gone extinct yet.
You see, you want to work on protecting the animals out there.
You want to work on getting the market for ivory in Asia down
so you're not using 25,000 elephants a year.
But at the same time, conservation biologists are realizing
that bad news bums people out.
And so the Red List is really important, keep track of
what's endangered and critically endangered, and so on.
But they're about to create what they call a Green List,
and the Green List will have species that are doing fine, thank you,
species that were endangered, like the bald eagle,
but they're much better off now, thanks to everybody's good work,
and protected areas around the world
that are very, very well managed.
So basically, they're learning how to build on good news.
And they see reviving extinct species
as the kind of good news you might be able to build on.
Here's a couple related examples.
Captive breeding will be a major part of bringing back these species.
The California condor was down to 22 birds in 1987.
Everybody thought is was finished.
Thanks to captive breeding at the San Diego Zoo,
there's 405 of them now, 226 are out in the wild.
That technology will be used on de-extincted animals.
Another success story is the mountain gorilla in Central Africa.
In 1981, Dian Fossey was sure they were going extinct.
There were just 254 left.
Now there are 880. They're increasing in population
by three percent a year.
The secret is, they have an eco-tourism program,
which is absolutely brilliant.
So this photograph was taken last month by Ryan
with an iPhone.
That's how comfortable these wild gorillas are with visitors.
Another interesting project, though it's going to need some help,
is the northern white rhinoceros.
There's no breeding pairs left.
But this is the kind of thing that
a wide variety of DNA for this animal is available in the frozen zoo.
A bit of cloning, you can get them back.
So where do we go from here?
These have been private meetings so far.
I think it's time for the subject to go public.
What do people think about it?
You know, do you want extinct species back?
Do you want extinct species back?
(Applause)
Tinker Bell is going to come fluttering down.
It is a Tinker Bell moment,
because what are people excited about with this?
What are they concerned about?
We're also going to push ahead with the passenger pigeon.
So Ben Novak, even as we speak, is joining the group
that Beth Shapiro has at UC Santa Cruz.
They're going to work on the genomes
of the passenger pigeon and the band-tailed pigeon.
As that data matures, they'll send it to George Church,
who will work his magic, get passenger pigeon DNA out of that.
We'll get help from Bob Lanza and Mike McGrew
to get that into germ plasm that can go into chickens
that can produce passenger pigeon squabs
that can be raised by band-tailed pigeon parents,
and then from then on, it's passenger pigeons all the way,
maybe for the next six million years.
You can do the same thing, as the costs come down,
for the Carolina parakeet, for the great auk,
for the heath hen, for the ivory-billed woodpecker,
for the Eskimo curlew, for the Caribbean monk seal,
for the woolly mammoth.
Because the fact is, humans have made a huge hole
in nature in the last 10,000 years.
We have the ability now,
and maybe the moral obligation, to repair some of the damage.
Most of that we'll do by expanding and protecting wildlands,
by expanding and protecting
the populations of endangered species.
But some species
that we killed off totally
we could consider bringing back
to a world that misses them.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: Thank you.
I've got a question.
So, this is an emotional topic. Some people stand.
I suspect there are some people out there sitting,
kind of asking tormented questions, almost, about,
well, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute,
there's something wrong with mankind
interfering in nature in this way.
There's going to be unintended consequences.
You're going to uncork some sort of Pandora's box
of who-knows-what. Do they have a point?
Stewart Brand: Well, the earlier point is
we interfered in a big way by making these animals go extinct,
and many of them were keystone species,
and we changed the whole ecosystem they were in
by letting them go.
Now, there's the shifting baseline problem, which is,
so when these things come back,
they might replace some birds that are there
that people really know and love.
I think that's, you know, part of how it'll work.
This is a long, slow process --
One of the things I like about it, it's multi-generation.
We will get woolly mammoths back.
CA: Well it feels like both the conversation
and the potential here are pretty thrilling.
Thank you so much for presenting. SB: Thank you.
CA: Thank you. (Applause)